The following content
is provided by a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I just want to be
explicit about it because with
all of the abstraction of QAM
looking at it in terms of
Hilbert filters and all of that,
you tend to forget that
what's really going on in terms
of implementation is
something very, very simple.
We said that what we were
doing with QAM is, we're
trying to essentially build two
PAM systems in parallel.
So what we do is, we have
two different data
streams coming in.
Each one there's a new signal,
each t seconds. t is the time
separation between times when
we transmit something.
So the sequence of
symbols come in.
What we form is then --
well, actually this
isn't a real operation.
Because everybody does this in
whatever way suits them.
And the only thing that's
important is getting from here
over to there.
And what we're doing in doing
that is taking each of these
signals, multiplying them by a
pulse, to give this waveform
the pulses delayed according
to what signal it is.
And if you like to think of that
in terms of taking the
signal and viewing it as an
impulse, so you have a train
of impulses weighted by
these values here.
And then filtering that, fine.
That's a good way to
think about it.
But, at any rate you
wind up with this.
With the other data stream which
is going through here --
yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You couldn't argue
that was band limited also.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: But it's band limited
in the same way.
I mean, visualize --
I mean, the Fourier transform of
p of t minus k t is simply
the Fourier transform of p of
t, which is multiplied by a
sinusoid in f at this point.
So it doesn't change the
bandwidth of that.
In other words, when you take a
function and you move it in
time, the Fourier transform is
going to be rotating in a
different way.
But its frequency components
will not change at all.
All of them just change
in phase because
of that time change.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: When you look at it
in frequency, well no, because
we're adding up all
these things in
frequency at that point.
But each one of these pulses
is still constrained within
the same bandwidth.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The transform of a
pulse train does not look like
a pulse train in
frequency, no.
When you take a pulse train
in time, and you take the
transform of each one of these
pulses, what you get is a
pulse which, where in frequency
there is a rotation.
In other words, the
phase is changing.
But in fact, what you wind up
with is a pulse within the
same frequency band.
I mean, simply take the Fourier
transform and look at
it, and see which frequencies
it has in it.
In they don't change.
And when you weight it with
coefficients, the Fourier
transform will be scaled, will
be multiplied by a scalar.
But that won't change which
frequencies are there, either.
So in fact, when
you do this --
I should make that clearer
in the notes.
It's a little confusing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It'll be band limited
in the same way,
though, yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It won't
look the same.
But the Nyquist criterion
theorem remains the same.
I mean, if you look at the proof
of it, it's -- well I'll
go back and look at it.
I think if you look at it, you
see that it actually --
I think you see that this time
variation here in fact does
not make any difference.
I mean, I know it doesn't
make any difference.
But the question is, how to
explain that it doesn't make a
difference.
And I'll go through this.
And I will think about that.
And I'll change the
notes if need be.
But anyway, it's not something
you should worry about.
Anyway.
What happens here is, you get
this pulse train, which is
just a sum of these pulses.
And they all interact
with each other.
So at this point we have
intersymbol interference.
We multiply this by
a cosine wave.
We multiply this
by a sine wave.
And what we get then is
some output, x of t.
Which is in the frequency
band.
But if you take the low pass
frequency here, which goes
from 0 up to sum w, up at
passband, we go from f c minus
w to f c plus w.
Same thing here.
So we have this function, which
is then constrained.
But it's a passband constraint
to twice the frequency which
we have here.
When we take x sub t, and
we try to go through a
demodulator.
The thing we're going to
do is to multiply,
again, by the cosine.
Multiply again by the sine.
Incidentally, this is minus
sine and minus sine here.
When you implement it, you can
use plus sine or minus sine,
whichever you want to.
So long as you use the same
thing here and there.
It doesn't make any
difference.
It's just that when you look at
things in terms of complex
exponentials, this turns
into a minus sine.
Oh, and this turns into
a minus sine.
We then filter by q of t.
We filter this by q of t.
The same filter.
And we wind up then going
through the T-spaced sampler.
The T-spaced sampler and the
output use of k prime.
And the reason for this is that
if you look at the system
broken right here, this is
simply a PAM waveform.
And when we take this PAM
waveform, the only thing we're
doing is we're multiplying
it by a cosine.
Then we're multiplying
it by a cosine again.
When we get a cosine squared
term, half of it comes back
down to baseband.
Half of it goes up to twice
the carrier frequency.
And this filter, in principle,
is going to filter out that
part at 2 times the
carrier frequency.
And it's also going to do the
right thing to this filter.
To turn it into something where,
when we sample, we
actually get these components
back again.
So the only thing that's going
on here is simply, this is a
PAM system where, when we
multiply by cosine twice, the
thing we're getting is a
baseband component again,
which is exactly the same
as this quantity here.
Except it's --
why, I when I multiply this
by this, don't I have
to divide by --
don't I have to multiply by 2?
I don't know.
But we don't.
And when we get all through the
thing we come out with u
sub k prime, and we come out
with u sub k double prime.
It is easier to think about
this in terms of complex
frequencies.
When we think about it in terms
of cosines and sines,
we're doing it that way because
we have to implement
it this way.
Because if you implement a
Hilbert filter, you're taking
a complex function, filtering it
by complex waveform, which
means you've got to build
four separate filters.
One to take the real part with
the real part of the filter.
The real part with the complex
part of the filter.
Also the imaginary part of the
waveform with the real part of
the filter, and so forth.
So you don't implement it that
way, but that's the easy way
to look at what's happening.
It's the easy way
to analyze it.
This just does the same thing.
When we use this double sideband
quadrature carrier
implementation of QAM,
the filters p and q
really have to be real.
Why do they have to be real?
Well, because otherwise, we're
mixing what's going on here
with what's going on here.
In other words, you can't take
-- this will not be a real
waveform, so you can't just
multiply it by a cosine wave.
In the other implementation we
had, you have this, which is a
complex waveform, plus
this, which is
another complex waveform.
You multiply it by e to
the 2 pi i f c t.
And then you take the
real part of it.
And everything comes
out in the wash.
Here we need this to be real and
this to be real in order
to be able to implement this
just by multiplying by cosine
and multiplying by sine.
So the standard QAM signal
set makes it just
parallel PAM systems.
If, in fact, you don't use a
standard QAM set; namely, if
these two things are mixed up
in some kind of circular
signal set or something, then
what comes out here has to be
demodulated in the same way.
So you don't have the
total separation.
But the real part of
the system is the
same in both cases.
I think the notes for a little
confusing about that.
Finally, as a practical detail
here, we have talked several
times about the fact that
every time people do
complicated filtering, and
complicated filtering involves
very sharp filters.
Every time you make a very sharp
filter at baseband, the
way you do it is, you
do it digitally.
Namely, you first take
this waveform.
You sample it very, very rapidly
at a rapid pace.
And then you take those digital
signals and you pass
those through a digital
filter.
And that gives you the
waveform that you're
interested in.
When you do that, you're faced
with having a waveform coming
into the receiver which has
a band down at baseband.
Which it has width w.
You also have a band up at twice
the carrier frequency.
And if you sample that whole
thing, according to all of the
things we've done with aliasing
and everything, those
samples mix what's up at twice
the carrier frequency with
what's down here at baseband.
And you really have to do some
filtering to get rid of once
or twice the carrier
frequency.
This really isn't much of a
practical issue, because you
can hardly avoid doing that much
filtering just in doing
the sampling.
I mean, you can't build the
sampler that doesn't filter
the waveform a little bit too.
But you have to be conscious of
the fact that you have to
get rid of those double
frequency terms before you go
into the digital domain.
So, you have to think of it as
a little bit of filtering
followed by a rapid
sampler, followed
by a careful filtering.
Which does this function
q of t here.
OK.
Want to talk a little bit about
the number of degrees of
freedom we have when
we do this.
If we look at quadrature
amplitude modulation, anytime
you get confused about
bandwidths, it's probably
better to look at the sample
time, t, which is something
that never changes.
And that always remains
the same.
When you look at the sample
spacing, the baseband
bandwidth, as we've seen many
times, the nominal baseband
bandwidth is 1 over 2t.
Namely, that's what's called
the Nyquist bandwidth.
It's what you get if you use
sinc functions, which strictly
puts everything in
this baseband and
nothing outside of it.
And we've seen that by using
the Nyquist criterion and
building sharp filters, we can
make the actual bandwidth as
close to this as we
want to make it.
When we modulate this up to
passband, we're going to have
a passband bandwidth
which is 1 over t.
Because, in fact, this baseband
function is going
from minus 1 over 2t
to plus 1 over 2t.
When we modulate that up, we get
something that goes from f
c minus 1 over 2t to
f c plus 1 over 2t.
Which is really an overall
bandwidth of 1 over t.
If we look at this over a large
time interval, t0, we
have two degrees of freedom.
Namely, the real part and
the imaginary part.
Namely, we have two different
real number signals coming
into this transmitter.
Each t seconds.
So that over a period of t0,
some much larger period, we
have t0 over capital T different
signals that we're
transmitting.
Each of those signals has two
degrees of freedom in it.
So we wind up with 2 t0 times
w real degrees of freedom.
Namely, 2 t0 over T. There's 2
t0 times w, where w is the
passband bandwidth.
What I want to do now, to show
you that actually nothing is
being lost and nothing is being
gained, is to look at a
baseband system where you use
pulse amplitude modulation.
But, in fact, you use
a humongously wide
bandwidth to do this.
So it becomes something like
these ultra-wideband systems
that people are talking
about now.
You use this very, very wide
bandwidth, and you see how
many signals you can pack
into this very wide
bandwidth using PAM.
And what's the answer?
There are 2 t0 w 0 real
degrees of freedom.
And a baseband bandwidth w 0.
This is what we determine when
we were dealing with PAM.
It simply corresponded to the
fact that the baseband
bandwidth was 1 over 2 t 0.
Therefore we got two signals
coming in, each 1 over w 0.
So this was the number of real
degrees of freedom we have.
Now, the thing we want
to do is to take
this humongous bandwidth.
And to say, what happens if
instead of using this wide
bandwidth system, we use a lot
of little narrow bands.
So we make narrow bands send QAM
in the narrow bands, where
in fact we're packing signals
into the real part and the
imaginary part, which is what
we decided we ought to do.
And how do these two
systems compare.
Well, if we take a very wide
bandwidth w0, with lots of
little bandwidths, w, up at
various passbands, all stacked
on top of each other.
Like here's zero.
Here's w0 which is up at five
gigahertz or whatever you want
to make it.
We put lots of little
passbands in here,
each of width w.
And the question is how many
different frequency
intervals do we get?
How many different signals can
we multiplex together here by
using different frequency
bands?
Which is exactly the way people
who use QAM normally
transmit data.
Well, the answer is,
you get w0 over w
different bands here.
So how many degrees of
freedom do you have?
Well, we said we had 2 t 0 w
real degrees of freedom with
each QAM system.
We have w0 over w different QAM
systems all stacked on top
of each other.
So, when you take w equals w0
over m you wind up with 2 t0
w, 2 t0 w 0 real degrees of
freedom, overall using QAM.
Exactly the same thing
if you use PAM.
This corresponds to these
orthonormal series we were
thinking about, where we were
thinking in terms of taking
segmenting time, and then using
a Fourier series within
each segment of time.
And looking at the number
of different
coefficients that we got.
And we then looked at these sinc
weighted expansions of
the same type.
We got the same number of
degrees of freedom.
This is simply saying that PAM
and QAM use every one of those
degrees of freedom.
And there aren't any more
degrees of freedom available.
If you're stuck with using some
very large time interval
t0 and some very large frequency
interval, w0, you're
stuck with that many
real degrees of
freedom, and real waveform.
There's nothing else available,
and PAM and QAM are
perfectly efficient
as far as their
user spectrum is concerned.
They both do the same thing.
How about single sideband?
That does the same thing too.
I mean, with single sideband,
you're sending real signals
but you cut off half the
bandwidth at passband.
So, again, you get the same
number of signals for unit
time and per unit bandwidth.
And most systems, except double
sideband quadrature
carrier, which is just obviously
wasting bandwidth,
all do the same thing.
So, it's not hard to
use all of these
available degrees of freedom.
And the only thing that makes
these degrees of freedom
arguments complicated is,
there's no way you can find
the pulse, which is perfectly
limited to 1 over w in time
and 1 over w in bandwidth.
If you make it limited
in time, it
spills out in bandwidth.
If you make it limited
in bandwidth, it
spills out in time.
So we always have to fudge a
little bit as far as seeing
how these things go together.
Let's talk about one sort of
added practical detail that
you always need in
any QAM system.
In fact, you always need it
in a PAM system, also.
And you need to do it
somehow or other.
There's this question of, how
do you make sure that the
receiver is working on the same
clock as the transmitter
is working on?
How do you make sure that when
we talk about a cosine wave at
the receiver, the phase of that
cosine wave is, quote,
the same as the phase
at the transmit?
So, if the transmitted waveform
at the upper passband
-- at positive frequencies
is u of t times e to
the 2 pi i f c t.
This is this is one of the
reasons why you want to think
in terms of complex notation.
If you try to analyze
QAM phase lock using
cosines and sines --
I mean, you're welcome
to do it, but it's
just a terrible mess.
If you look at it in terms of
complex signals, it's a very
easy problem.
But it's most easy when you look
at it in terms of just
what's going on at positive
frequencies.
So the thing we're doing here
is, when we modulate, we're
taking u of t.
We multiply by e to
the 2 pi i f c t.
What happens to any arbitrary
phase that we have in the
transmitter?
Well, nothing happens to it.
We just define time in such
a way that it's not there.
At the receiver, we're going to
be multiplying again by e
to the minus 2 pi i f c t.
There's going to be some phase
in there because the
receiver's clock and
the transmitter's
clock are not the same.
Now, the thing which is
complicated about this is that
at the receiver there's some
propagation delay from what
there is at the transmitter.
So what we're really saying here
is that when the waveform
u of t gets to the receiver --
in other words, after we
demodulate, what do we get?
That's the practical
question to ask.
I mean you have an arbitrary
sinusoid, complex sinusoid at
the transmitter.
You have an arbitrary complex
sinusoid at the receiver.
When you multiply by e to the 2
pi i f c t, and then at the
receiver you demodulate by
multiplying e to the minus 2
pi i f c t, there's some added
phase in there just because
you're multiplying by
some sinusoid in
an arbitrary phase.
What do you wind up with when
you get done with that?
You get the received waveform,
u of t, times e to the i phi.
Now, suppose you're sending
analog data.
What happens here?
Well, with analog data,
you're absolutely up a
creek without an oar.
There's nothing you can do.
But with digital data there
is something you can do.
And I think this diagram makes
it clear, if you can see the
little arrows on it.
What you're transmitting is
QAM signals out of a QAM
constellation.
So the signals -- so you're
either transmitting this, or
this, or this, or this,
and so forth.
Now, at the receiver we haven't
analyzed noise yet.
We're going to start doing
that later today.
But if you visualize noise being
added up at passband and
then coming down to baseband
again, we can visualize what's
happening as the noise just adds
something to each one of
these points.
I mean, assuming that we know
exactly what the timing is for
the time being.
So that we sample
at exactly the
right time at the receiver.
And that's a separate issue.
But let's assume that we do
know what the timing is.
We do sample at the
correct time.
And the only question we're
trying to find out now is, how
do we choose this phase right
on this sinusoid that we're
using at the demodulator.
Because at the demodulator,
there's no way to know whether
phi is zero or whether phi
is something else.
But after we got all done doing
this, if we sample at
the right time, what we're going
to receive, if there's
some small error in phase, is
that this diagram is all
rotated around a little bit.
Any time you send this point,
what you receive is going to
be a point up here.
If you send this point it's
going to be a point here.
If phi is negative, everything
will go the other wa.y How do
I know whether it's positive
phi or negative phi?
I don't.
I just do the same thing
either place.
Everybody I know who worries
about phase locked loops
ignores the sign and simply
makes sure that they're using
the same sign at the transmitter
and the receiver.
If they don't, when they build
it, the thing goes out of lock
immediately.
And they try switching the sign,
and if it works then,
they say uh-huh, I now
have the right sign.
I mean, it's like these
factors of two.
You always put them in
after you're done.
Anyway, I think I've
done it right here.
So the received waveform is now
going to be u of t times e
to the i phi.
It will have a little bit
of noise added to it.
So what we're getting, then,
if you look at a scope, or
whatever people use as
scope these days.
And people have done this for
so many years that they call
this an eye pattern.
And what they see, after looking
at many, many received
signals, is little blobs around
each of these points
due to noise.
And they also see the set
of points rotated
around a little bit.
And if the noise a small, and
if the phase error is small,
you can actually see this
diagram rotated around sitting
at some orientation.
And the question is, if you know
that's what's happening,
what do you do about it?
Well, if you have this diagram
rotated around a little bit,
you want to change the phase of
your demodulating carrier.
So the thing you do is, you
measure the errors that you're
making when you go from these
received signals.
And you make decisions
on them.
You then look at the phase
of these errors.
If all the phases are positive,
then you know that
you have to change the phase
of this carrier one way.
And if all the phases are
negative, you change
it the other way.
Now, why does this work?
It works because these clocks
are very stable clocks.
They wander in phase slowly.
I mean, you can't lock
them perfectly.
And since they wander
in phase slowly.
And since you're receiving data
quickly, you can average
this carrier recovery over
many, many data symbols.
Which is what people do.
So, you average it
over many symbol.
And you gradually change
the phase as the
phase is getting off.
How much trouble does that cause
in trying to actually
receive the data?
Hardly any.
Because if the phase changes
are slow enough, then you
average over a long enough
interval, the actual phase
errors are going to be
extraordinarily small.
So it's the noise errors that
look big and the phase errors
that look very small.
When you average over a long
period of time, the noise is
sort of independent from
one period to another.
So the noise averages out.
And the thing you see, then,
is the phase errors.
So, so long as the phase is slow
and the noise is quick,
you first decode the data.
After you decode the data, you
average over what the phase
errors are.
And then you go and you
change the clock.
And people spend their lives
designing how to make these
phase lock loops.
And there's a lot of interesting
technology there.
But the point is, the idea is
almost trivially simple.
And this is what it is.
Since the phase is changing
slowly, you can change the
phase slowly.
You can keep the phase error
very, very small.
And therefore, the data recovery
due to the noise
works almost as well as if you
had no phase error at all.
How do you recover from
frequency errors?
Well, if I can recover from
phase errors, I'm recovering
from frequency errors also.
Because I had this clock which
is running around.
And I'm slaving the clock at the
receiver to the clock at
the transmitter.
So, so long as I have very
little frequency error to
start with, simply by keeping
this phase right, I can also
keep the carrier frequency
right.
Because the phase is just going
around at the speed it's
supposed to be going around.
So this will also serve as a
frequency lock as well as a
phase lock.
When you're trying to do both
together, you build the phase
lock loop a little different,
obviously.
What's the problem with this?
You look this diagram, and you
say, OK, suppose there's some
huge error where for a long
period of time, things get
very noisy.
What's going to happen?
Well, if you can't decode the
data for a long period of
time, suddenly these phase
errors build up.
The channel stops being noisy.
And what could have happened
is that your phase could be
off by pi over 2.
Which means what you see, what
you should be seeing is this.
What you're actually
seeing is this.
You can't tell the difference.
In other words, you decode
every symbol wrong.
Because you're making an
error of pi over 2 in
every one of them.
You decode this as this, you
decode this as this, this as
this, and so forth.
So every point is wrong.
What will you do to
recover from this?
I mean, suppose you were
designing a system where in
fact you had no feedback to
the transmitter at all.
You have feedback from the
transmitter, you just,
obviously every once in a
while you stop and you
resynchronize.
You don't have any feedback,
what do you do?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Differential
phase shift key, yes.
I mean, this isn't quite
phase shift key, but
it's the same idea.
In other words, the thing that
you do is, you don't --
usually when the data is coming
in, you don't map it
directly into a signal point.
The thing that you do is map the
data into a phase change
from one period of
time to the next.
I mean, you map it into
an amplitude.
And then you map it into
a change of phase
in this set of points.
Or change of phase within
this set of points.
Or a change of phase within
the outer set of points.
And then if, due to some
disaster, you get off by pi
over 2, it won't hurt you.
Because the changes are still
the same, except for the
errors that you make when
this process starts.
So in fact, a lot of these
things that people have been
doing for years, you would think
of almost immediately.
The only thing you have to be
careful about, when you invent
new things to build new systems,
is you have to have
somebody to check whether
somebody else
has a patent on it.
So, you invent something and
then you check whether
somebody else patented it.
So that's what this slide says.
Bingo.
It's time to go on to talk
about additive noise and
random processes.
How many of you have seen
random processes before?
How many of you have seen it
in a graduate context as
opposed to an undergraduate
context?
A smaller number.
Many of you, if you got your
degrees outside of the US, if
you've studied this as an
undergraduate, you probably
know what students here have
learned in their various
graduate courses.
So you might know a
lot more about it.
What we're going to do here is
I'll try to teach you just
enough about random processes
that you can figure out what's
going on with the kinds
of noise that we're
looking at this term.
Which involves two
kinds of noise.
One, something called additive
noise, which is what we're
going to be dealing with now.
And the other is much later,
when we start studying
wireless systems, we
have to deal with a
different kind of noise.
People sometimes call it
multiplicative noise, but
really what it is, is these
channels fade in various ways.
And the fading is a
random phenomena.
And therefore we have to learn
how to deal with that in some
kind of probabilistic
way also.
So the thing we're going to do
is we're going to visualize
what gets received as what gets
transmitted plus noise.
Now, at this point, I've said
OK, we know how to deal with
compensating for phase errors.
So we'll assume that
away, it's our
usual layered approach.
What kind of other assumptions
are we making here?
When I say the received signal
is the transmitted
signal plus the noise.
Well, I mean, I could look at
this and say, this doesn't
tell me anything.
This is simply defining
the noise.
There's the difference
between what I
receive and what I transmit.
So when I say this is additive
noise, I'm not saying anything
other than the definition of the
noise, is this difference.
But when we look at this,
we're really going to be
interested in trying to analyze
what this process is.
And we're going to be interested
in analyzing what
this is as a process also.
Here, I'm just looking
at sample functions.
And what I'd like to be able
to do is say this sample
function, namely, what's going
into the channel, is one of a
large set of possibilities.
If it weren't one of a large
set of possibilities, there
would be no sense at all to
transmitting it, because the
receiver would know what
it was going to be.
And you wouldn't have to
transmit it, it would just
print it out at the output.
So, this is some kind of
random process which is
determined by the binary data
which is coming into the
encoder and the signals
it gets mapped
into, and so forth.
This reviewing of some kind
of noise waveform.
What we're going to assume is
that in fact these two random
phenomena are independent
of each other.
And when I write this, you would
believe that if nobody
told you to think about it.
Because it just looks like
that's what it's saying.
Here's some noise phenomena
that's added to the signal
phenomenon.
If in fact I told you, well,
this noise here happens to be
twice the input then
you'd say, foul.
What I'm really doing is calling
something noise which
is really just a scaling
of the input.
Which is really a more
trivial problem.
So we don't want to do that.
Another thing I could try to do,
and people tried to do for
a long time in the communication
field, was to
say, well, studying random
processes is too complicated.
Let me just say there's a
range of possibilities,
possible things for
what I transmit.
There's a range of possible
waveforms for the noise.
And I want to make a system
that works for both these
ranges of different things.
And it just turns out that
that doesn't work.
It works pretty well for
the transmitter.
It doesn't work at all
for the noise.
Because sometimes the noise
is what it should be.
And sometimes the noise
is abnormally large.
And when you're trying to decide
what kind of coding
devices you want to use, what
kind of modulation you want to
use, and all these other
questions, you really need to
know something about the
probabilistic structure here.
So we're going to view
this as a sample
function of a random process.
And that means we're going to
have to say what a random
process is.
And so far, the only thing we're
going to say is, when we
talk about it as a random
process, we'll call it capital
N of t instead of
little n of t.
And the idea there is that for
every time, for every instant
of time, when you talking about
random processes, you
usually call instants
of time epochs.
And you call them epochs because
you're using time for
too many different things.
And calling it an epoch helps
you keep straight what you're
talking about.
So for each epoch t, n of
t is a random variable.
And this little n of t is just
some sample value of that
random variable.
So we're going to assume that
we have some probabilistic
description of this very large
collection of random variables.
And the thing which makes this
a little bit tricky,
mathematically is that we have
an uncountably infinite number
of random of variables
to worry about here.
x sub t is known at the
transmitter but
unknown at the receiver.
And what we're eventually
concerned about is, how does
the receiver figure out
what was transmitted.
So we'd better view
x of t as a sample
function of a random process.
x of t, from the receiver's
viewpoint.
Namely, the transmitter
knows what it is.
This is this continual problem
we run into with probability.
When you define a probability
model for something, it always
depends on whose viewpoint
you're taking.
I mean you could view my voice
waveform as a random process.
And in a sense it is.
As far as I'm concerned it's
almost a random process,
because I don't always
know what I'm saying.
But as far as you're concerned,
it's much more of a
random process than it
is from my viewpoint.
If you understand the English
language, which all of you do,
fortunately, it's one kind
of random process.
If you don't understand that,
it's just some noise waveform
where you need a much more
complicated model
to deal with it.
So everything we have to do here
is based on these models
of these random processes, which
are based on reasonable
assumptions of what we're trying
to do with the model.
When we do this in terms of
random processes, we have the
input random process, and we
have the noise random process.
And if we add up two random
processes, it doesn't take
much imagination to figure out
that what we get is another
random process.
It's random both because of
this and because of this.
Now, we implicitly are assuming
a whole bunch of
things when we write things
out this way.
We're not explicitly assuming
them, but what we want to do
is explain the fact that we're
implicitly assuming them and
then make it explicit.
One of those things that we're
doing here is, we're avoiding
all attenuation in what's
been transmitted.
We've been doing
that all along.
We've been talking about
received waveforms as being
equal to the transmitted
waveform.
Which means that we're assuming
that the receiver
knows what the attenuation is.
And if it knows what the
attenuation is, there's no
point in putting in this scale
factor everywhere.
So we might as well look at
what's being transmitted as
being the same as what's being
received, subject to this
attenuation, which is just some
known factor which we're
not going to consider.
There's also this question
of delay.
And we're assuming that the
delay is known perfectly.
So that assumption is
built into here.
y of t is x of t without
delay, plus z of t.
And now, after studying these
modulation things, we can add
a few more things which are
implicitly put into here.
One of them is that we know what
the received phase is.
So that in fact we don't
have any phase
error on all of this.
So we're saying, let's
get rid of that also.
So we have no timing error,
no phase error.
All of these errors are
disappearing because what we
want to focus on is just the
errors that come from this
additive noise.
Whatever the additive
noise is.
But we want to assume that
this additive noise is
independent of this process.
So we're saying, when we know
all of these things about --
or when the receiver knows all
of these things about what's
being transmitted, except for
the actual noise waveform, how
do we deal with the problem?
We implicitly mean that z of
t is independent of x of t,
because otherwise it would be
just very misleading to define
n z of t as the difference
between what you receive and
what you transmit.
So we're going to make that
assumption explicit here.
These are standing assumptions
until we start to study
wireless systems.
And another standing assumption
which we'll make is
the kind of assumption
we've been making in
this course all along.
Which some people like,
usually theoreticians.
And some people often don't
like, namely practitioners.
But which if both the
theoreticians and
practitioners understood better
what the game was, I
think they would agree to
doing things this way.
And what we're going to do here
is, we're not going to
think of what happens when
people make measurements of
this noise and then try to
create a stochastic model of
it from all of these
measurements.
What we're going to do is more
in the light of what Shannon
did then when he invented
information theory.
Which is to say, let's try to
understand the very simplest
situations first.
If we can understand those
very simplest situations
namely, we will invent whatever
noise we want to invent.
To start to understand what
noise does to communication.
And we will look at the simplest
processes we can.
Which seem to make any
sense at all of us.
And then after we understand a
few of those, then we will
say, OK, what happens if
there's some particular
phenomenon going on
in this channel.
And when you look at what
practitioners do, what in fact
they do is, everything
they do is based on
various rules of thumb.
Where do these rules
of thumb come from?
They come from the theoretical
papers that were written 50
years before, if they're very
out of date practitioners.
25 years before if they're
relatively up to date
practitioners.
Or one year before if they're
really reading all the
literature as it comes out.
But rules of thumb usually
aren't based on what's
happening as far as papers
are concerned now.
It's usually based on some
composite of what people have
understood over a large
number of years.
So in fact, the way you
understand the subject is to
create these toy models.
And the toy models are
what we're going
to be creating now.
Understand the toy models, and
then move from the toy models
to trying to understand
other things.
This is the process we'll be
going through when we look at
this additive noise channel,
which doesn't make much sense
for wireless channels,
as it turns out.
But it's part of what you deal
with on a wireless channel.
And then, on a wireless channel,
we'll say, well, are
these other effects
concerned also?
And we'll try to deal with
these other effects as an
addition to the effects that
we know how to deal width.
We've already done that as far
as phase noise is concerned.
Namely, we've already said that
since phase effects occur
slowly, we can in fact get rid
of them almost entirely.
And therefore we don't have
to worry about them here.
So, in fact we have done what
we've said that we believe
ought to be done.
Namely, since we now know how to
get rid of the phase noise,
we're now looking at additive
noise and saying, how can we
get rid of that.
Actually, if you look at the
argument we went through with
phase noise, we were really
assuming that we knew how to
deal with channel noise
as part of that.
And in fact when you get done
knowing how to deal with
channel noise, you can
go back to that
phase locked loop argument.
And you'll see a little more
clearly, or a little more
precisely, what's
going on there.
When we started talking about
waveforms, if you remember
back to when we were talking
about compression, we really
faked this issue of
random processes.
If you remember the thing we
did, everything was random
while we were talking about
taking discrete sources and
coding for them.
When we then looked at how
do you do quantization on
sequences of real numbers or
sequences of complex numbers,
we again took a probabilistic
model.
And we determined how to do
quantization in terms of that
probabilistic model.
And in terms of that
probabilistic model, we
figured out what ought
to be done.
And then, if you remember, when
we went to the problem of
going from waveforms to
sequences, and our pattern
was, take a waveform.
Turn it into a sequence.
Quantize the sequence, then
encode the digital sequence.
We cheated.
Because we didn't talk at all
about random processes there.
And the thing we did instead is,
we simply converted source
waveforms to sequences and
said that only the
probabilistic description of
the sequence is relevant.
And, you know, that's
actually true.
Because so long as you decide
that what you're going to do
is go from waveforms to
sequences, and in fact you
have decided on which particular
orthonormal
expansion you're going to use,
then everything from there on
is determined just by what you
know about the probabilistic
description of that sequence.
And everything else
is irrelevant.
I mean, each waveform maps
into a sequence.
When you're going back,
sequences map into waveforms,
at least in this L2 sense,
which is what determines
energy difference.
And energy differences usually
are criterion for whether
we've done a good job or not.
So, in fact, we could avoid the
problem that way simply by
looking at the sequences.
And it makes some sense to do
that because we're looking at
mean square error.
And that was why we looked
at mean square error.
But now we can't do
that any more.
Because now, in fact, the noise
is occurring on the
waveform itself.
So we can't just say, let's turn
this into a sequence and
see what the noise on the
waveform does to the sequence.
Because, in fact, that won't
work at this point.
So random process z of t is
a collection of random
variables, one for
each t and r.
So, in other words, this is
really a collection of an
uncountably infinite number
of random variables.
And for each epoch
t, the random
variable z of t is a function.
Capital Z of t and omega.
Omega is the sample point we
have in this sample space.
Where does the sample
space come from?
We're imagining it.
We don't know any way
to construct a
sample space very well.
But we know if we study
probability theory that we
need a sample space to talk
about probabilities.
So we're going to imagine
different sample spaces and
see what the consequences
of those are.
I mean, that's the point of
this general point of view
that we have.
That we start out looking at
simple models and go from
there to complex models.
Part of the model is the sample
space that we have.
So for each sample point that
we're dealing with, the
collection --
I should have written
this differently.
Let me change this
a little bit to
make it a little clearer.
z of t omega for t and r
is a sample function
z of t; t and r.
So if I look at this, as a
function of two variables.
One is time and one is this
random collection of
things we can't see.
If I hold omega fixed,
this thing becomes
a function of time.
And in fact it's a sample
function, it's the sample
function corresponding to that
particular element in the
sample space.
And don't try to ask what
the sample space is.
The sample space --
I mean, the sample
point here --
really specifies what this
sample function is.
It specifies what the input
It specifies what everything
else you're interested in is.
So it's just an abstract
entity to say, if we're
constructing probabilities
we need something to
construct them on.
So that's the sample space that
we can construct these
probabilities on.
The random processes --
Oh.
OK.
We want to look at two different
things here.
Here we're looking at a fixed
sample point, which means that
this process for a fixed sample
point corresponds to a
sample function.
If instead I look a fixed time,
a fixed epoch, t and r,
and I say what does this
correspond to as I look at z
of t and omega over all
omega in this big
messy thing, fix t.
What do I have there?
I have a random variable.
If I look at a fixed t, and
I'm looking over the whole
sample space, that's what you
mean by a random variable.
If I look at -- if I hold omega
fixed and look over the
time axis, what I have
is a sample function.
I hope that makes it a little
clearer what the game we're
playing is.
Because this random thing, the
random process that we're
dealing with, we can best
visualize it as a function of
two things, both time
and sample point.
The sample point in this big
sample space is what controls
everything.
It tells you what every random
variable in the world is.
And what the relationship
of every random variable
in the world is.
So, a random process is defined,
then, by some rule
which establishes a joint
density for all finite values
of k, all particular sets of
time, and all particular
arguments here.
What am I trying to do here?
I'm trying to admit right from
the outset that if I try to
define this process for an
uncountably infinite number of
times, I'm going to be
dead in the water.
So I had better be happy with
the idea of, at least in
principle I would like to be
able to find out what the
joint probability density
is for any finite set
of points in time.
And if I can find that,
I will say I have
defined this random process.
And I'll see what I
can do with it.
So we need rules that let
us find this kind
of probability density.
That's the whole
objective here.
Because I don't know how to
generate a random process that
does more than that,
that talks about
everything all at once.
You can read mathematics texts
to try to do this, but I don't
know any way of getting from
that kind of general
mathematics down to anything
that we could make sense about
in terms of models of reality.
The favorite way we're going to
generate this kind of rule
is to think of the random
process as being a sum of
random variables multiplied
by orthonormal functions.
In other words, we will have
sample values in time, z of t,
which are equal to z sub
i phi sub i of t.
And for each sample function
in time, we will then have,
for that particular time, as I
vary over capital Omega, I'm
going to be varying over
the values of z sub i.
These are just fixed
functions.
And what that's going to give
me is a set of random
variables here.
So in a way we're doing very
much the same thing as we did
with functions.
With functions we said, when
we're dealing with these the
equivalence classes, things get
very, very complicated.
The way we're going to visualize
a function is in
terms of an orthonormal
expansion.
And with orthonormal expansions,
if two functions
are equivalent, they
both have the
same orthonormal expension.
So now we're saying the same
thing when we're dealing with
this more general thing, which
is stochastic processes.
This is really what the signal
space viewpoint of
communication is.
It's the viewpoint that you view
these random processes in
terms of orthonormal expansions
where the
coefficients are random
variables.
And if I deal with a finite
number of random variables
here, everything
is very simple.
Because you know how to add
random variables, right?
I mean, at least in principle,
you all know how
to add random variables.
You've been doing that
any time you take
a probability class.
A quarter of the exercises you
deal with are adding random
variables together and finding
various things about the sum
of those random variables.
So that's the same thing we're
going to be doing here.
The only thing is, we can do
this for any real value of t,
just by adding up this fixed
collection of random variables.
And you add it up at a different
arguments here
because as t changes, phi
sub i of t changes.
And this is sort of what we did
when we were talking about
source waveforms.
It's very much the same idea
that we were looking at.
Because with source waveforms,
when we turned the waveform
into a sequence we were turning
the waveform into a
sequence by in fact using an
orthonormal expansion.
And then what was happening is
that the coefficients in the
orthonormal expansion, we were
using to actually represent
the random process.
So we're doing the
same thing here.
The same argument.
So, somehow we have to
figure out what these
joint densities are.
So, as I said before, when we
don't know what to do, we make
a simple assumption.
And the simple assumption we're
going to make is that
these random variables at
different points in time, of
noise, we're going to assume
that they're Gaussian.
And a normal Gaussian random
variable; this, I hope, is
familiar to you, has the density
1 over the square root
of 2 pi, e to the minus
n squared over 2.
So it's just density that has
this nice bell-shaped curve.
It's an extraordinarily
smooth thing.
It has a mean of 0.
It has a variance of 1.
How many of you could
prove that the
variance of this is 1?
Well, in a while you'll all
be able to prove it.
Because there are easy
ways of doing it.
Other than looking at a table of
integrals, which we'll do.
An arbitrary Gaussian random
variable is just where you
take this normal variable.
These normalized Gaussian random
variables are also
traditionally called
normal variables.
I mean, they have such a central
position in all of
probability.
And when somebody talks about
a normal random variable --
I mean, there's sort of the
sense that random variable
should be normal.
That's the typical thing.
It's what should happen.
And any time you don't have
normal random variables,
you're dealing with something
bizarre and strange.
And that's carrying it a little
too far, but in fact,
when we're looking at noise,
that's not a bad idea.
If you shift this random
variable by a mean z bar, and
you scale it by -- excuse
me, scale it by sigma.
Then the density of the result
becomes 1 over the square root
of 2 pi sigma squared, e to the
minus z minus z bar over 2
sigma squared.
In other words, the shifting
just shifts the
whole thing by z bar.
So this density peaks up around
z bar, rather than
peaking up around 0,
which makes sense.
And if you scale it by sigma,
then you need a
sigma in here, too.
When you have this probability
density, you're going to be
scaling it this way.
Scaling it that way is what
we mean by scaling it.
If you scale it this way to make
sigma squared larger, the
variance larger, this thing
still has to integrate to 1.
So you have to pop it down
a little bit also.
Which is why this sigma squared
appears here in the
denominator.
So anytime we scale a random
variable, it's got to be
scaled this way.
And it's also got to
be scaled down.
So that's why these
Gaussian random
variables look this way.
We're going to be dealing with
these Gaussian random
variables so much that we'll
refer to this random variable
as being normal with mean
z bar and sigma
variance sigma squared.
And if we don't say anything
other than it's normal, we
mean it's normal with mean
0 and variance 1.
Which is the nicest
case of all.
It's this nice bell-shaped curve
which everything should
correspond to.
They tend to be good
models of things
for a number of reasons.
One of them is the central
limit theorem.
And the central limit theorem,
I'm not going to state it
precisely here.
I'm certainly not going
to prove it.
One of the nastiest things to
prove in probability theory is
the central limit theorem.
It's an absolute bear.
I mean, it seems so simple.
And you try to prove
it, and it's ugly.
But, anyway, the central limit
theorem says that if you add
up a large number of Gaussian
random variables, of
independent Gaussian random
variables, and you scale the
sum down to make it
variance one, you
have to scale it down.
Then when you get all done
adding them all up, what you
wind up with is a Gaussian
random variable.
This is saying something a
little more precise than the
law of large numbers.
The law of large numbers says
you add up a bunch of
independent or almost
independent random variables.
And you scale them down.
And you get a mean, which
is something.
This is saying something more.
It's saying you add them all up,
and you scale them down in
the right way.
And you get not only the mean,
now, but you also get the
shape of the density
around the mean.
Which is this Gaussian shape,
if you add a lot of them.
It has a bunch of extremal
properties.
In a sense, it's
the most random
of all random variables.
Not going to talk about that,
but every once in a while, one
of these things will come up.
When you start doing an
optimization in probability
theory, over all possible random
variables of a given
mean and variance, you often
find that the answer that you
come up with either when you
maximize or when you minimize
is Gaussian.
If you get this answer when you
maximize, then what you
get when you minimize is usually
a random variable,
which is zero or something.
And vice versa.
So that either the minimum
or the maximum of a
problem makes sense.
And the one that makes
sense, the
answer is usually Gaussian.
At least, it's Gaussian
for the problems
for which it's Gaussian.
But it's Gaussian for an
awful lot of problems.
It's very easy to manipulate
analytically.
Now, you look at that density,
and you say, my God, that
can't be easy to manipulate
analytically.
But in fact, after you get
used to two or three very
small tricks, in fact you'll
find out that it's very easy
to manipulate analytically.
It's one of the easiest random
variables to work with.
Far easier than a binary
random variable.
If we add up a bunch of binary
random variables,
and what do you get?
You get a binomial
random variable.
And binomial random variables,
when you add up enough of
them, they get uglier
and uglier.
Except they start to
look Gaussian.
These Gaussian random variables,
if you add up a
bunch of them, and
what do you get?
You get a Gaussian
random variable.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Central limit theorem
applies to random
variables or Gaussian
random variables?
PROFESSOR: Central
limit theorem
applies to random variables.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, I'm sorry.
I shouldn't have.
No.
I said, when you add a bunch of
Gaussian random variables,
you get exactly a Gaussian
random --
when you add up a bunch of
jointly Gaussian random
variables, and we'll find out
what that means in a while,
you get exactly a Gaussian
random variable.
When you add up a bunch of
random variables which are
independent, or which are close
enough to independent,
and which have several
restrictions on them and you
scale them the right way.
What you get as you add more and
more of them, tends toward
a Gaussian distribution.
And I don't want to state
all of those conditions.
I mean, we don't need all
those conditions here.
Because the only thing we're
relying on is when we look at
noise, we're looking at a
collection of a very large
number of phenomena.
And because we're looking at
a very large number of
phenomena, we can sort of model
it as being an addition
of a lot of little
random variables.
And because of that, in an
enormous number of situations,
when you look at these things,
what you get is fairly close
to a Gaussian shape.
And it's a model that everybody
uses for noise.
If you read papers in the
communication field, or in the
control field, or in a bunch
of other fields, and people
start talking about what happens
when noise enters the
picture, sometimes they will
talk about their model for the
noise process.
Sometimes they won't.
But if they don't talk about
what noise model they're
using, it's a very safe bet that
what they're using is a
Gaussian process model.
In other words, this is the
kind of model people use
because it's a model
that makes a
certain amount of sense.
Now, there's one other thing you
ought to be aware of here.
It's something that we've talked
about a little bit in
other contexts.
When we're looking at a noise
waveform that you have to deal
with in a modem or something
like that, this modem only
experiences one noise waveform
in its life.
So, what do we mean by saying
that it's random?
Well, it's an act of
faith, in a sense.
But it's not so much.
Because if you're designing
communication equipment, and
you're cookie cuttering
cellphones or something like
that, or something else, what
you're doing is designing a
piece of equipment which is
supposed to work in an
enormous number of
different places.
So that each one you're
manufacturing is experiencing
a different waveform.
So that as far as the designing
the device is
concerned, what you're
interested in is not that one
waveform that one of these
things experiences, but in
fact the ensemble of waveforms
that all of them experience.
Now, when you look at the
ensemble of waveforms that all
of these things experience, over
all of this large variety
of different contexts; noise
here, noise there, noise
there, suddenly the model of a
large collection of very small
things makes even
better sense.
Because in each context, in
each place, you have some
forms of noise.
When you look at this over all
the different contexts that
you're looking at, then suddenly
you have many, many
more things that you, in a
sense, are just adding up if
you want to make a model here.
So we're going to use this
model for a while.
We will find out that it leads
us to lots of nice things.
And so forth.
So, we said that we'd be happy
if we could deal with at least
studying a random process over
some finite set of times.
So it makes sense to
look at a finite
set of random variables.
So we're going to look at a
k-tuple of random variables.
And we're going to call that
-- what do you think we're
going to call a k-tuple
of random variables?
We're going to call it
a random vector.
In fact, when you look at
random vectors, you can
describe them as being elements
of a vector space.
And we're not going to do that
because most of you are
already sufficiently confused
about doing functions as
vectors, and adding on the idea
of a random process as a
vector would be very unkind.
And we're not going to
do it because we
don't need to do it.
We're simply calling these
things vectors because we want
to use the notation of vector
space, which will be
convenient here.
So, if we have a collection of
random variables n 1 to n k,
and they're all IID, independent
identically
distributed.
They're all normal with mean
zero and variance one, the
joint density of them is what?
Well, you know what the
joint density is.
If they're independent and
they're all the same, you just
multiply their densities
together.
So it's 1 over 2 pi
with a k over 2.
e to the minus n 1
squared minus n 2
squared, and so forth.
Divided by 2.
That's why this density
form is a
particularly convenient thing.
You have something
in the exponent.
When you have independent
random variables,
you multiply densities.
Which means you add what's
in the exponent.
Which means everything
is very nice.
So you wind up adding up all
these sample values for each
of the random variables.
With our notation looking at
norm squared, this is just the
norm squared for this sequence
of sample values.
And look at the sequence of
samples values is a actual
vector, n 1 up to n sub k.
So we wind up width the norm
of the vector n squared
divided by 2.
If you draw a picture of that,
you have spherical symmetry.
Every set of sample vectors
which have the same energy in
them has the same probability
density.
If you draw it in two
dimensions, you get --
it looks like a target where
the biggest probability
density is in here, and the
probability density goes down
as you move out.
If you look at it in three
dimensions, if that same
thing's looked at in a sphere.
And if you look at it in four
dimensions, well, it's the
same thing, but I can't draw
it, I can't imagine it.
But it's still a spherical
symmetry.
In the one minute that I have
remaining, I'm going to --
I might derive a Gaussian
density.
I'm going to call a bunch of
random variables zero-mean
jointly Gaussian if they're
all derived by linear
combinations on some
set of normal IID
Gaussian in random variables.
In other words, if each of them
is a linear combination
of these IID random variables, I
will call the collection z 1
up to z k a jointly Gaussian
random variable.
In other words, jointly Gaussian
does not mean that z
1 is Gaussian, z 2
is Gaussian, up
to z k being Gaussian.
It means much more than that.
It means that all of them are
linear combinations of some
underlying set of independent
random variables.
In the homework that was passed
out this time, you will
look at two different ways of
generating a pair of random
variables which are each
Gaussian, but which are not
jointly Gaussian.
Which you can't view
in this way.
So this is important.
Jointly Gaussian makes sense
physically because when we
look at random variables, we say
it makes sense to look at
Gaussian random variables
because of a collection of a
lot of noise variables.
If you look at two different
random variables, each of them
is going to be a collection of
different small noise variables.
And they're each going to be
some weighted sum over a
different set of noise
variables.
So it's reasonable to expect
each of them to be expressible
in this way.
I guess I'm not going to derive
what I wanted to derive.
I'll do it next time.
It's easier to think of
this in matrix form.
In other words, I'll take the
vector of sample values, z 1
up to z sub k.
Each one of them is a linear
combination of these normal
random variables, n
1 up to n sub n.
So I can do it as z equal
to matrix a times n.
This is a vector of
real numbers.
This is a vector of real
numbers, this is a matrix.
And if I make this a square
matrix, than what we're doing
is mapping each of the unit
vectors, each single noise
vector, into the i'th
column of a.
In other words, if I have a
noise vector where n 1 is
equal to 0, n 2 is equal to 0,
n sub i is equal to 1 and
everything else is equal to 0,
what that generates in terms
of this random vector z is
just the vector a sub 1.
So.
What I'm going to do when I come
back to this next time
is, if I take a little cube in
the n space, and I map it into
what goes on in the z space,
this unit vector here is going
to map into a vector here.
The unit vector here is going
So cubes map into
parallelograms.
Next time, the thing we will
say is, if you look at the
determinant of a matrix, the
most fundamental definition of
it, is that it's the volume of
a parallelepiped.
In fact, it's the volume
of this parallelepiped.
So we'll do that next time.